jeanne d'arc est né à fa sol mais l'on
dampremy adoré après un stage au bois de
boulogne
elles passent rapidement son cap2
bergère écoule une jeunesse paisible
dans les verts pâturages lors un bon lit
moutons s'il vous plaît
les moutons familles doivent à oyem
autant il est beau ce temps les gars
turin ma mère dans la salle en six ans
qu'elle allait aller 1-4
et nous retrouvons jeanne d'arc plus
belle que jamais
passons les moutons la dame jeanne d'arc
vous êtes déjà une star c'est vos clips
qu'est ce que vous faites avec la laine
de vos moutons pastry côté pur leur
manque de temps à ces jeunes bac à
savoir à ses fans a lancé roy savait pas
enchérir à témoin
mais ce jour depuis pas un jour comme
les eaux sa radio se grouille à café
hier à diouf à riviera notarié danger
elle entendit des voies occupées
aux aigreurs
la can do va boutu du sang bleu et je
vais voter les anglais c'était charles
gabriel qu'il a plu affolée elle réunit
un attelage de fortune et cours au
village vite les classes
onze jours c'est dingue j'ai une
nouvelle incroyable annonce ça y est il
est perdu maintenant qu'est ce que
raconte j'entends des voix faut que
j'aille brouter les anglais en offrant
brutale beauties en heure de france
ça y est ça recommence mais aussi moins
banal bon vous devez les pousser
d'écouté pas cette conne toi si tu veut
pas bosser pour moi tu restes tout et
personne n'y donne croit incomprise de
tous
elle prend le tgv défense à chinon au
château de charles vii
c'est ce que dit donc c'est incroyable
mais j'entends des voix faut que j'aille
bouter les anglais hors de france
j'aurais des voies ferrées en rendez
vous électoral sur personne ils veulent
croire
elle arrive au château du roi bonjour
fier hallebardiers que j'aille voir le
roi parce qu'il faut que j'aille brouter
les anglais en foire après les anglais
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait pasqua
camarades hallebardiers assemblée
générale à 10 heures dans le grand
réfectoire n'oubliez pas vos cartes
d'autres partis merci
bob black sam reprend j'entends encore
des voix je vais utiliser un stratagème
oh la jolie girafe à doit y avoir ni
elle savait déjouer tous les pièges
bonjour mon roi dites moi j'ai entendu
des voix faut que j'aille broutaient les
anglais en france
alors qu'est ce que je dois faire besoin
de ce soir mais bon faudrait une armée
oui jean claude une armure ou c'est
froid non je n'y crois pas bon et
maintenant tu te casses on va bouter les
anglais hors de france se discute pas
elle se fait encercler
mais pour chasser les anglais et l'usaid
un nouveau stratagème à il est 5 heures
au moins et c'est tant mieux
hier ils ont poncé anglais
trahi par les siens et par son roi elle
est arrêtée jeu se fera dans la nuit
beh de brouter les anglais on refera
alors se déguise c'est mardi gras bas
puisque je vous dis free jeanne barrès
un et moi je suis là polo au lycée
philippe bouvard a longtemps fait
elle est jugée par le clergé que préside
le tristement célèbre évêque cochon ses
veaux cochons
ah non moi ce rallye c'est le port
accusez vous quelque chose à dire pour
votre défense
oui ok prout m l'évêque cauchon que
pensez vous de la situation
pensez vous qu'elle est coupable
monsieur attendu que le jury si présent
reconnu coupable de sorcellerie la
prévenue répondre au patronyme de jeanne
d'arc habitant 10,8 relâche appel à dons
et vie a attendu que le crime de
sorcellerie repas cynodrome de mort
jeanne d'arc seraient condamnés soit
être puni par l'odieuse fois écouter un
disque devenir maîtres 450 brûlé mois à
ses bourreaux marcel merci allez vas-y
marcel chauffe
vous connaissez michael est de retour
selon son habitude amuriza 3
mais qu'est ce que vous faites mais
alors à quoi ça sert que du coup il se
tait car 4